le gouvernement qui redoute une nouvelle
vague de l'épidémie c'est alors que le
virus reste actif sur le territoire 348
nouveaux décès en 24 heures pour un
total de près de 27 mille morts en
charge du déconfinement le haut
fonctionnaire jean castex a prévu un
plan de re confinement en urgence s'il
s'avérait nécessaire
les explications de craie claire n'est
qu à peine des confiné que le
gouvernement français a déjà prévu un
plan de re confinement d'urgence en cas
de rechute de l'épidémie si d'ici la fin
de la première phase du déconfinement le
2 juin prochain
le nombre de cas positifs par jour
venait à doubler alors le gouvernement
prendrait plusieurs mesures et il
n'écarte pas la possibilité notamment de
reconfirmer tout ou une partie du
territoire national
si si le virus ne joue des tours si tous
les dispositifs que nous avons envisagée
ne s'applique pas bien si l'un
l'ensemble chacun chacune et chacun
d'entre nous ne fait pas les les mesures
n'accomplit pas les mesures de
précaution il ya effectivement un risque
peut y avoir aussi jeudi dit tout à
l'heure des raisons inexpliquées de ce
virus
j'ai plus qu'elle le député me parlait
tout à l'heure la corée du sud
et effectivement il est réapparu
alors qu'aucune des conditions ne
paraissait a priori réunis en tout cas
tels qu'on peut les expliquer les
scientifiques tabac bon donc
effectivement je vais pas leur dire il
est raisonnable d'anticiper toute
l'egypte hôtel le plan de re confinement
veut préserver la réversibilité des
mesures c'est pourquoi le désarmement
des lits de réanimation à l'hôpital se
fait de manière très progressive
si la france devait faire face à une
nouvelle vague de contamination la
réouverture de ces lits devrait pouvoir
s'effectuer très rapidement en 24 48 ou
72 heures selon les lie l'état lui
demande aux entreprises de poursuivre et
d'encourager le recours au télétravail
au moins jusqu'à la fin du mois de juin
en attendant l'ouverture début juin
d'une deuxième phase en fonction de
l'évolution de l'épidémie
jean castex insiste sur l'implication
des français à respecter les gestes
barrière